bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat avez vous déjà entendu parler des
néonicotinoïdes peut-être pas et bien ce
sont des substances chimiques qui sont
contenus dans certains pesticides
elle aurait la particularité d'attaquer
les insectes pollinisateurs et plus
particulièrement l'attaqué leur système
nerveux central entraînant une forte
mortalité chez ces insectes
dans ce contexte le groupe écologiste au
sénat a déposé une proposition de
résolution pour demander au gouvernement
et bien d'intervenir auprès de l'union
européenne pour faire interdire tous les
pesticides contenant ces substances
alors la proposition de résolution n'a
pas été adoptée ici au sénat mais les
débats ont été très houleux
je propose de revoir une séquence
particulièrement joël labbé chef de file
du groupe écologiste sur ce texte a
retiré sa cravate dans l'hémicycle il a
enfreint le règlement pour dénoncer la
manière dont se tenait les débats on
découvre tout de suite la séquence dans
l'hémicycle l'ordre du jour appelle
l'examen de la proposition de résolution
relative à la préservation des insectes
pollinisateurs de l'environnement et de
la santé et à un moratoire sur les
pesticides de la famille des
néonicotinoïdes présenter des
néonicotinoïdes en application de
l'article 34 de la constitution par
monsieur joël labbé et plusieurs de ses
collègues c'est une demande du groupe
écologiste dans le débat la parole et à
monsieur joël labbé du groupe écologiste
auteur de la proposition de résolution
monsieur l'abbé vous avez la parole mon
cher collègue
non
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues sénatrices
et sénateurs
en préambule je voudrais vous dire que
mon propos d'aujourd'hui ne sera pas un
discours de discussion générale j'aime
pas les discours
mon souhait est qu'il puisse être perçu
comme un manifeste un manifeste pour le
respect de la vie il s'adresse à vous en
direct mes chers collègues puisque mon
rôle ma responsabilité est de tout faire
pour vous convaincre
mais il ne s'adresse pas qu'à vous il
s'adresse à toutes les personnes
concernées par le sujet qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui
en premier lieu le monde agricole mais
aussi à l'ensemble de la population des
citoyennes des citoyens directement
intéressés par ces sujets et ils sont
nombreuses
cette population qui est foule
sentimentale se manifeste pour la vie
s'adresse aussi tout particulièrement à
nos jeunes les générations nouvelles qui
ont soif d'idéal
dans ce monde qui tangue et bien sûr en
perspective aux générations futures
pas facile de se trouver dans la
situation de présenter un texte qui
dérange parce que je sais qu'il dérange
qui dérange autant qu'il dérange bien
au-delà de ce que j'aurais pu imaginer
vous commencez à me connaître je vais le
faire avec toute la force de mes
convictions
pourtant il est tout simple ce texte il
ne devrait déranger personne
bien au contraire je vous en lit la
phrase essentielle que vous devez
connaître par coeur tant elle est simple
et soft le sénat invite le gouvernement
à agir auprès de l'union européenne
sur l'ensemble des pesticides
néonicotinoïdes tant que les risques
graves graves sur la santé humaine ne
seront pas écartés
il ya sur l'environnement
sur la forme monsieur le ministre ce
n'est pas une injonction
c'est juste une invitation avec en toile
de fond bien sûr même s'il n'est pas
écrit le principe de responsabilité ce
principe qui est à la base même de notre
rôle politique que l'on soit dans le
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
où que l'on soit parlementaire ce que
nous sommes mais chers collègues membres
de la représentation nationale ce qui
n'est quand même pas rien principe de
responsabilité il fallait en parler sur
un texte d'invitation au gouvernement de
bien vouloir relayer nos préoccupations
au regard de cette responsabilité auprès
de l'union européenne
nos préoccupations qui répercute les
préoccupations d'une foule importante de
nos populations
on appelle ça une résolution ce n'est
quand même pas une révolution
bien que bien que ce soit une toute
petite révolution qui doit s'inscrire
dans la logique de ce qu'edgar morin
défini si joliment comme la nécessaire
métamorphose sociétal avec derrière cela
une part d'indignation cette indignation
à laquelle nous invite son complice
stéphane hessel donc une simple
résolution une invitation
je vous la relire et havas à la fin de
mon propos alors après ceux nécessaires
préambule revenons-en à ce texte
je développe mon propos en cinq parties
je vous exposerai tout d'abord par quel
cheminement j'en suis arrivée là
enfin enfin ici ensuite je vous
exposerai les raisons scientifiques
agronomique environnementale est aussi
économique qui ont motivé cette
résolution
l'aspect essentiel de la santé humaine
sera abordée tout à l'heure lors de la
prise de parole de ma collègue
le gist aline archimbaud aline que tout
le monde sait très impliquée sur les
sujets liés à la santé
le point suivant évoquera les
alternatives qui ne pas se limiter au
seul fait de remplacer ces produits par
des produits de substitution
l'agriculture doit faire sa transition
en réintégrant les principes de
l'agronomie ce que vous appelez
l'agroécologie monsieur le ministre qui
ne peut porter ce nom en persistant dans
l'utilisation des néonicotinoïdes puis
j'oserais aborder le spirituel question
majeure
oui le spirituel
ce n'est pas habituel en politique et
pourtant ce n'est pas habituel mais je
le faire je vais le faire quand même en
sénateurs inhabituel improbable parfois
imprévisibles enfin je vous parlerai de
politique
notre unique raison d'être ici la
politique comment je vois la politique
comment je vis la politique comment
j'espère encore la politique une
politique qui doit rimer avec éthique
tout cela sans jamais oublier l'objectif
à atteindre les abominables criminel que
sur les pesticides néonicotinoïdes oui
vous avez bien entendu criminelle je
développerai et j'accuserai tout à
l'heure alors par quel chemin
j'en suis arrivé là après 37 ans d'une
très heureuse et très riche vie d'élu
local
moi qui n'ai eu jamais de projets de
carrière politique
et l'on n'est toujours pas d'ailleurs
j'ai pris le risque d'être candidat aux
élections sénatoriales de 2011 élue
surprises inattendues
je siège ici depuis trois ans en qualité
de sénateur du morbihan
et comme nul n'est parfait sénateurs
écologistes
dès mon arrivée
et d'ailleurs je suis heureux et fier
d'être de ce groupe
dès mon arrivée en immersion dans cette
majestueuse maison qu'est le palais du
luxembourg
j'ai intégré la mission d'information
sur les pesticides et leur impact sur la
santé
initialement la mission était double
impact sur la santé humaine et impact
sur l'environnement
le volet santé humaine a été si lourd
quand c'est deux mois de travail
on a dû s'y limiter il faudrait
d'ailleurs que l'on voit à ce qu'une
suite il soit donné cette mission avait
vu le jour à l'initiative de notre
collègue nicole bonnefoy sénatrice de
charente rapporteur de la mission
et cette mission était présidée par
sophie primas notre collègue l'ump
brillamment présider et c'était une
mission pluri politique et nous avons
particulièrement bien travaillé ensemble
lors de cette première mission j'ai pu
me rendre compte de la richesse du
travail de notre assemblée
hors les murs travail qui doit annoncer
des fluides législatif dans les murs
j'ai été particulièrement tous mes
collègues qui participaient j'ai été
particulièrement choquée ou toucher
d'entendre les propos de ce spécialiste
le professeur sultan pédiatre andy creux
en doctrine hologue à montpellier
concernant les aspects notamment de
puberté précoce
le professeur rémy b son chirurgien au
chu de lille spécialisée maintenant dans
les meules malformations génitales des
nouveau-nés masculin tellement ces
malformations sont nombreuses et aussi
le dr nadine ou et des médecins
spécialistes en cancer de la vessie
derrière tout cela c'est avéré sont les
pesticides
si on les 109 recommandations de la
mission
voté à l'unanimité près de la moitié ont
déjà été prises par les ministères
agriculture et santé
le reste est intégré au fur et à mesure
dans les projets de lois dont la loi
d'avenir agricole monsieur le ministre
et sous forme de proposition de loi
d'initiative parlementaire je l'ait
expérimentée en élaborant la proposition
de loi visant à interdire l'usagé des
pesticides sur les espaces publics des
collectivités à partir de 2020 et dans
les jardins domestique pour 2022
proposition qui a été adoptée en février
c'était pour moi une étape juste une
étape c'est pas mon affaire que de
mettre mon nom au bas d'une aubade une
loi m'intéressant tout particulièrement
au domaine agricole et alimentaire
organise chaque année un colloque au
sénat au printemps 2013 juste avant
l'examen de la loi de l'avenir agricole
le thème en était l'agroécologie ce que
doit être la gouaille écologie le 5 juin
2014 le colloque que j'organisais en
liens étroits avec l'union nationale des
apiculteurs français s'intitulait pour
une agriculture respectueuse des
pollinisateurs à c'est à cette occasion
étaient réunis à certain nombre
d'experts et de chercheurs
internationaux de professionnels de
l'apiculture d'acteurs associatifs et de
parlementaires pour l'ensemble des
intervenants l' usage des
néonicotinoïdes avait un impact avéré
sur le déclin des colonies d'abeilles
les preuves sont très claires nous
sommes face à une menace qui pèse sur la
productivité de notre milieu naturel et
agricole
il convient de planning et de planifier
leur suppression
à l'échelle mondiale je cite là le
britannique dave wilson biologiste et
happy docks de l'université du sussex
c'est suite à ce colloque que j'ai
déposé la présente résolution sénat
odile aux 10 le 19 juin conjointement
avec le député de dordogne germinal
peiro rapporteur de la loi d'avenir
agricole déposé un texte identique
absolument identique à l'assemblée
quelques jours après ce dépôt était
publié les conclusions
on d'une méta étude reprenant l'ensemble
de la littérature scientifique sur 15
pays concernant le sujet des
néonicotinoïdes cette étude transversale
la task force and systemic pestis side
visait à étudier les causes potentielles
du déclin des insectes depuis les années
ce travail gigantesque mené par 29
chercheurs dont dave wilson et le
français jean marc bonmatin chercheur en
biophysique moléculaire au cnrs
d'orléans a révélé un effondrement
massif de certaines espèces d'insectes
bien au delà des seuls pollinisateurs à
partir du début des années 90 qui
commence en europe de l'ouest avant de
s'étendre rapidement à l'est et au sud
en scientifique indépendant sans aucun a
priori
ils ont découvert que l'effondrement de
ces populations coïncide avec
l'introduction des pesticides
systémiques persistant et neurotoxiques
de la famille des néonicotinoïdes
l'étude démontre que ce n est
néonicotinoïdes touche aussi les oiseaux
insectivores commun ils accumulent des
doses importantes de ces produits à la
toxicité extrêmement élevé ils ont aussi
un impact sur les petits mammifères qui
se retrouve exposé de par leur proximité
avec les cultures et aussi par la
gestion de graines enrobées et de
plantes traitées mais c'est aussi
l'ensemble de la faune et de la
microfaune du sol agricole qui est
impactée en première ligne sont avec
sont affectés les vers de terre
exposés à des niveaux élevés via le sol
et les plantes
monsieur le ministre vous le savez bien
vous qui leur avaient rendu un rib un
vibrant hommage lors de la troisième
conférence environnementale celui que
vous avez eu que celui que vous avez
nommés votre camarade le ver de terre
est un des plus grands marqueurs de la
bonne santé des sols et de la
biodiversité
je vous cite trois tonnes de verre à
l'hectare savoureux venu 280 tonnes de
terre pendant ce temps là vous n'avez
pas besoin de la bouée ce qui est vrai
alors monsieur le ministre
l'étude
outre qu'ils sont ces vers de terre en
première ligne de cet empoisonnement
empoisonnement généralisée bien sûr que
quand on a des camarades
moi mes camarades je les appelle mes
potes mais quand on a de bons camarades
monsieur de ministres ou de bons potes
on fait tout pour qu'il ne soit pas
empoisonner à propos du travail du sol
la taupe qui a mauvaise réputation la
taute et pourtant véritable mineur de
fond des sols elle joue elle aussi un
rôle essentiel dans la vie des sols je
n'ai rien lu à son sujet pour le moment
mais ce que je sais c'est que les vers
de terre constitue 80% de sa nourriture
alors voilà les tops sont aussi
forcément touché tout ça monsieur le
ministre à ça nous donne le vertige aux
chers collègues le sol l'avis même du
sol est mise à mal lors d'un colloque
organisé à l'assemblée nationale en fin
d'année dernière lors de la journée
mondiale des sols on a pu se rendre
compte combien les sols à l'échelle
mondiale avait perdu de leur fertilité
on parle de la qualité de l'eau qui va
mal on le sait de la qualité de l'air
qui va mal aussi
on le sait on en oubliait à la qualité
du sol qui va très mal
il va falloir faire quelque chose et de
manière globale sinon dans quel état
allons nous laisser cette terre pourtant
nourricière qu'est le sol lors de cette
journée j'ai entendu cette superbe
formule la vie fait le sol et le sol
fait la vie alors faisant en sorte que
cesse le massacre en cette année de
conférences internationales non je vais
pas avoir le temps j'y viendrai après
pour la conférence internationale
en tout cas la question de la fixation
du carbone dans les sols ne peut se
faire qu'à la condition que les
maintiennent vivant et donc qu'on arrête
de les empoisonner je pèse mes mots et
j'accuse
enfin s'il était encore besoin d'en
rajouter sur ce plaidoyer à charge dans
l'eau plusieurs espèces d'invertébrés
aquatiques sont également touchés voilà
pour ses études
on peut encore en commander des tonnes
monsieur le ministre mais dans quel but
attendre attendre encore bien sûr il
serait difficile de croire que tout ça
se passe silencieusement sans aucun
impact sur la santé
aline archimbaud aline archimbaud en
parlera tout à l'heure l'aspect
économique en ces temps difficiles que
traverse notre économie on entend dire
attention l'environnement les petites
bêtes les petites fleurs c'est bien joli
mais il faut quand même nourrir les
populations de la planète
pensez à l'emploi c'est là le grand
discours classique de ce qu'on appelle
la profession en particulier son grand
maître incontesté et incontournable que
certains appellent le ministre de
l'agriculture vis ça ça me plairait pas
monsieur le ministre
et bien sûr les films les firmes
regrouper je les nomme peut-être qu'ils
sont là derrière luis pépé l'union des
industries pour la protection des
plantes
quelle protection des plantes quelle
protection des sols quelle protection de
la ville apporte
or la valeur économique de la
pollinisation que ce qu'on parle
économie a été estimée à 153 milliards
d'euros par an la seule europe affiche
un déficit de 13 points 4 millions de
colonies d'abeilles en france comme en
allemagne -2 50% des colonies
nécessaires à la pollinisation sont
encore présentes
quant à la valeur économique que
représente la vie du sol agricole celle
là qui fait sa fertilité renouvelables
sans fin si on la respecte
je n'en ai pas encore les chiffres mais
cette valeur est inestimable et à terme
équivalente au toit économique de
l'ensemble de l'agriculture mondiale
n'allez pas imaginer qu'on pourra
nourrir la planète en 2050
en se passant du sol ce serait une folie
à propos de ces valeurs lors de mon
intervention ici à la tribune lorsque
vous étiez au bain mathieu le ministre
en fin d'année dernière
je vous avais fait une proposition cache
un peu à la volée de faire mener une
étude complète chiffrées écoutez bien
noté bien je suis frais mesurant
précisément les coûts d'externalités
négatives de l'agriculture productiviste
et les bénéfices chiffres et en services
rendus par les aménités apportées par
les agricultures alternatives notamment
l'agriculture biologique dont on parle
beaucoup trop peu aujourd'hui monsieur
munissez solennellement que je vous le
demande de cette tribune de mener cette
étude afin qu afin que la population
française plus choisir mais la
population européenne aussi puis choisir
et soutenir ce qu'elle souhaite comme
agriculture et ainsi permettre la
véritable transition tant attendu un mot
sur le nouveau plan ecophyto le premier
plan même si on va trouver des petites
choses le premier plan c'est une
catastrophe
c'est un plan un acte manqué alors il ya
des intentions derrière le second plan
mais si un premier signe comme celui
d'aujourd'hui
on n'était pas capable de le donner on
serait dans le renoncement
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je retiendrai la citation d'andré pochon
mise en avant dans le rapport potier qui
a ça je vous invite à lire ce qu'il a
écrit monsieur andré pochon un paysan un
vrais paysans
comment se fait-il donc que
l'agriculture dite moderne est oubliée à
ce point les règles élémentaires de
l'agronomie
comment se fait-il qu'elle ait tourné le
dos à une agriculture durable qui
préserve l'avenir des hommes et de la
terre sans sacrifier le présent tout est
dit il est tard mais il n'est pas trop
tard par contre en 2025 il sera trop
tard
je vous l'avais annoncé je vais prendre
le temps madame la présidente j'en ai
plus pour longtemps
je vous l'avais annoncé que j'allais
aborder le spirituel
la fin du sac du siècle dernier il n'y a
pas si longtemps on citait encore
souvent ce grand visionnaire qu'était
andré malraux le 21e siècle sera
spirituel ou ne sera pas je trouve que
le site de moins en moins souvent ce
siècle est déjà là ceci avec la déjà 15
ans et le spirituel tarde à venir
je vous parle du spirituel que nos fois
croyant que l'on soit athée alors il
fallait que je trouve une autre
définition celle qui me convient où que
l'on soit agnostique mène vers le
respect des équilibres naturels dans
cette magnifique alchimie qui fait les
équilibres de la vie
enfin toujours sur le spirituel liés à
notre sujet je citerai une autre belle
pensée contemporaine
hubert reeves que tout le monde connaît
écoutez bien ça l'homme est l'espèce la
plus insensée
ils vénèrent un dieu invisible et
massacrent une nature visible sans
savoir que cette nature qu'il massacre
est ce dieu invisible qu'il vénère
c'était pour le couple est spirituelle
maintenant le politique et pourront
finir oui oui et pour en finir non on
peut pas le terminer sans parler de
politique
on ne réussira pas tout laisser tomber
vous pouvez ricaner je continuerai on ne
pourra pas réussir notre transition
qu'elle soit climatiques écologiques
agricoles énergétiques sans réussir la
transition politique et là on a du
boulot je voudrais dérangé sur les bancs
pas vous vous êtes là peut-être j'en ai
je sais que j'en ai dû ranger un certain
nombre par ci par là demande de ce vote
à scrutin public pour que chacun puisse
voter en son âme et conscience
parce que derrière moi c'est à la
conscience que je m'adresse parce que
moi je suis dérangé avec ma propre
conscience de laisser faire tout ça
comme ça et donc je le crir est c'est
pas le mot je le dirai toujours toujours
plus fort monsieur le ministre ce que
j'attends ce que j'espère encore
par rapport à ce texte là que ce soit au
moins un avis de sagesse qu'ils soient
donnés à l'assemblée des sages et com -
l'assemblée des chats des sages
s'étaient se détermine je tiens à vous
dire moi je vous apprécie je vous
respecte par contre l'esprit de ceux de
maisons commencent à mettre à me
déranger
alors il ya des symboles des fois faut
poser des actes mais près de la
présidence
il ya des symboles la cravate est
obligatoire hi-fi heureusement alors moi
moi j'ai fait des efforts je n'étais pas
habitué pour la porte et j'ai
tranquillement ça fait partie du jeu
maintenant je ne suis plus dans l'esprit
du du sénat qui règne qui règne
actuellement et la cravate je vais la
tombe et je vous chers collègues au
chocolat retour et écoutez moi je vous
laisse vous écoutez moi vous pouvez
continuer un petit peu c'est ça de moins
que roux vos collègues pour parler
puisque c'est une niche si vous avez
deux heures si vous voulez continuer
encore 3000 je vous les laisse ça sera
ça de moi pour vos collègues
ça vous prend des décisions non je crois
que c'est fait je tiens ça va quand
quant à vous l'avez vous pouvez
continuer de ricaner
mes chers collègues dans la suite du
débat la parole est à monsieur gérard
miquel pour le groupe socialiste vous
avez la parole mon cher collègue
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
la proposition de résolution qui nous
est soumise aujourd'hui par joël labbé
et un certain nombre de nos collègues à
bord d'une problématique très importante
qui occupent de plus en plus au débat et
suscite toujours plus d'attentes de la
part de la société civile
la question de l'impact des pesticides
sur notre santé notre environnement est
un effet majeur elle est au carrefour de
très nombreux enjeux et pose des
questions complexes qui nous concerne
tous en tant qu'élus et en tant que
citoyen comment faire face aux nouveaux
défis environnementaux qui s'imposent à
nous
quel modèle agricole alimentaire voulons
nous comment concilier protection de
notre biodiversité et productivité
agricole toutes ces questions nous les
posons tous notamment au travers des
différents textes de lois que nous
examinons le groupe socialiste du sénat
est particulièrement sensible à cette
question des pesticides et là démontre
avec force ces dernières années en 2011
à la demande de notre groupe
une mission commune d'information sur
les impacts des pesticides sur la santé
l'environnement a été créée en octobre
notre collègue nicole bonnefoy rendait
un rapport fort bien centaine de pros de
recommandation en juillet dernier nous
félicitions de voir de nombreuses
préconisations se concrétiser à d'ores
et déjà dans la loi d'avenir agricole
par ailleurs toujours dans ce cadre dans
le cadre de cette loi de nombreuses
avancées ont été portés par les
sénateurs socialistes et je reviendrai
plus longuement tout à l'heure cette ppr
aborde toutefois la question plus
précise des néonicotinoïdes une famille
particulière l'insecticide utilisé en
agriculture pour très fier des semences
des sols ou en pulvérisation cette
famille de produits intéresse plus
particulièrement les apiculteurs
qui envoie qui voit un enjeu majeur pour
les abeilles l'union nationale des
apiculteurs de france a d'ailleur
ailleurs été particulièrement active à
l'élaboration de cette bpr et nous
pouvons le comprendre le monde apicole
traverse en effet une crise depuis
plusieurs années la chute démographique
de la population d'abeilles est très
significative en france comme dans le
reste du monde
les pertes hivernales sont largement
supérieures à la normale et le taux de
mortalité des abeilles serait passé de
5% en 1995 à 40% aujourd'hui la
production de miel s'en trouve
mécaniquement impacté et atteignent des
niveaux historiquement bas en 20 ans
elle aura été divisé par près de trois
en passant de 35 mille tonnes par an
dans les années 90 à 15 mille tonnes en
4 en 2013 et selon certaines projections
dix mille tonnes en 2014
les apiculteurs subissent de plein fouet
cette crise structurelle et incrimine
particulièrement les néonicotinoïdes
comme causes majeures du déclin des
abeilles en france c'est pourquoi les
auteurs de cette ppr demande au
gouvernement d'intervenir auprès de
l'union européenne pour je cite une
interdiction de toutes les utilisations
de ces substances néonicotinoïdes tant
que les risques graves pour la santé
humaine animale et l'environnement ne
seront pas d'écarter les chers collègues
nous sommes tous conscients de la
situation dramatique dans laquelle se
trouve plongée nos apiculteurs nous
sommes j'en suis sûr tous d'accord pour
dire que des actions de soutien à la
filière apicole doivent être mises en
oeuvre pour préserver nos apiculteurs
qui font vivre nos territoires et
participe par là même à la préservation
notre digue biodiversité
pour autant les néonicotinoïdes ont un
impact sur la santé des insectes
pollinisateurs
il ne faut pas imputer à ces seules
substances la responsabilité du des
plaines de leur population
depuis plusieurs années les études
scientifiques tentent de largement à
démontrer que les causes sont
multifactorielles
et si si
follow asiatique varroa prédateurs
champignon parasite ou encore changement
climatique
c'est pourquoi j'aime bien ici à la
position majoritaire du groupe
socialiste du sénat sur ce texte
nous ne pouvons pas soutenir en l'état
cette ppr je tienne tout de suite à
préciser que cette position ne tiennent
pas à des raisons de fond mais bien des
raisons de forme une partagent en effet
tous l'impérieuse nécessité de préserver
nos insectes pollinisateurs
indispensables à un bon équilibre
écologique par ailleurs et d'une manière
générale nous sommes également tous
d'accord pour dire que nous devons
réduire significativement l'impact des
pesticides sur notre environnement et
notre santé
pour autant nous sommes nombreux à
penser que s'il faut agir avec force et
conviction
nous devons également usé de patience et
de concertation sur ces questions la
décision ne peut être unilatérales car
elle implique une multitude d'acteurs à
titre d'exemple si nous étions en
possibilité de voter une telle
interdiction car nous ne le sommes pas
comme je vous l'indiquais dans lequel
comme je vous l'indiquais dans quelques
instants
quelles solutions alternatives sérieuses
ou en mesure de proposer à nos
agriculteurs qui ont aujourd'hui recours
à ce type de produit pour le maïs le
colza l'orge ou le blé d'hiver beaucoup
s'inquiéter de cette interdiction de
principe et dénoncent une distorsion de
concurrence entre eux et le reste des
agriculteurs européens
bien évidemment si un enjeu de santé
publique majeur est constatée il faut
agir vite et nous l'avons déjà fait mais
si tel n'est le cas il faut privilégier
le dialogue pour faire bouger les lignes
dans la durée c'est ainsi que s'est
engagée la france depuis plusieurs
années sur la scène européenne
et je tiens ça dure ici le travail de
notre ministre l'agriculture sur ce
sujet je tiens dans les faits a rappelé
que la règlementation européenne ne
permet pas aux états membres d'autoriser
ou d'interdire une substance active en
l'occurrence ici les néonicotinoïdes les
états membres seulement la possibilité
de se prononcer hier sur les produits
eux mêmes
et cette possibilité nous en avons déjà
uv dès juin 2012
les auteurs de la ppl admettent la
france a été en première ligne sur ce
sujet en interdisant tout d'abord au
niveau national le crise air ohresser
puis en initiant au niveau européen une
procédure visant d'interdire les semis
de colzas traités par enrobage hotyat
méthode semble en mai 2013
la réglementation européenne à encadrer
l'utilisation de nenê nook
néonicotinoïdes avec le soutien actif de
la france la commission européenne en a
restreint l'utilisation de trois des
cinq substances actives cette famille de
pesticides du fait de leur nocivité sur
la population d'abeilles
cette mesure est entrée en vigueur le
1er décembre 2013 et une révision
dangerosité l'autre ont lieu dans les
deux ans concernant les deux substances
actives toujours autorisée du fait d'une
dangerosité bien moindres sur les
insectes pollinisateurs une réévaluation
de leurs risques pour les abeilles sera
conduite le cadre du réexamen général de
l'approbation de ces substances au
niveau européen
je crois savoir que monsieur le ministre
s'engagera pour que cette réévaluation
se fasse vite et nous nous en félicitons
par ailleurs l'autorité européenne de
sécurité alimentaire a proposé en juin
un cadre révisé de l'évaluation du
risque des phytosanitaires se cabre
prend en compte de manière plus large
le risque pour les abeilles domestiques
et certaines pollinisateurs sauvages
comme seule mission confirment en a
certainement les autorités françaises
participent activement aux travaux sur
ses nouvelles lignes directrices
la france est donc clairement engagée au
niveau européen sur la question des
pesticides
le dialogue est parfois difficile sur ce
sujet le ministre pourra nous le
confirmer il faut donc éviter d'envoyer
des signaux radicaux qui pourrait être
contre-productif notamment vis-à-vis nos
partenaires européens
en outre conformément à l'engagement du
président de la république
il faut cessèrent de sûr transposer les
directives européennes
nous sommes nombreux sur tous les bancs
de cette assemblée à partager ce constat
le monde agricole y est partie également
particulièrement attentifs parallèlement
au niveau national une démarche globale
du ministre l'agriculture a été engagée
pour encadrer davantage les produits
phytosanitaires et protéger les insectes
pollinisateurs
le plan de développement durable de
l'apiculture lancé le 8 février 2013
vise à diminuer la mortalité des
abeilles soutenir la recherche dans le
domaine apicole structurer le
développement du cheptel français et
encourager l'installation est organisée
dans la filière le plan ecophyto qui
vise la réduction de l'usagé des
pesticides d'ici à 2018 serait également
révisées et adaptées là le courant de
l'année 2015 dans le cadre de la loi
d'avenir agricole les avants des
avancées significatives ont été votés en
matière d'encadrement de l'utilisation
des pesticides et de promotion d'une
agriculture plus durable
je commencerai ici par l'une des plus
emblématiques à savoir le transfert de
la compétence de délivrance des
autorisations de mise sur le marché de
produits phytosanitaires des matières
fertilisantes et des adjuvants à lens s
pour plus d'efficacité et d'objectivité
les ministres en charge de l'agriculture
de l'environnement ou de la santé
pourront continuer à prendre des mesures
de restriction et d'interdiction de ces
produits en cas de risque avéré pour la
santé publique et l'environnement
ils garderont leur rôle en matière de
définition des lycées acceptable
d'approbation des substances actives au
niveau communautaire ou encore de la
mise en oeuvre de politiques publiques à
travers le plan ecophyto par ailleurs un
comité de suivi des autorisations de
mise sur le marché et créer au sein de
l'ansès il aura vocation à faire la
synthèse l'ensemble des éléments
d'appréciation permettant de prendre des
décisions fondées sur l'intérêt public
tout en assurant la cohérence des
actions à mener
une fois les autorisations délivrées de
plus cette loi consacre le projet agro
écologiques cher à notre ministre
l'agriculture dont la définition
désormais inscrit dans le code rural est
la suivante je cite un système de
production qui doit privilégier
l'autonomie des exploitations agricoles
et l'amélioration de leur compétitivité
en diminuant la consommation d'énergie
d'eau d'engrais de produits
phytopharmaceutiques et de médicaments
vétérinaires en particulier
antibiotiques la création d'un
groupement d'intérêt économique
environnemental vient d'incarner ce
projet et permettra d'opérer une
modification durable de nos systèmes de
production
il faut également noter la création à
l'initiative du groupe socialiste du
sénat d'un dispositif de phyto
pharmacovigilance dont la mission sera
de surveiller les effets indésirables
des produits phytosanitaires sur l'homme
et l'environnement
toujours à notre initiative l'émission
ne se dise positives ont été étendues à
la santé des abeilles domestiques
le groupe socialiste du sénat a
également instauré le principe d'une
présentation par lens s d'un rapport
annuel au parlement rendant compte de
ses activités relatives à l'évaluation
la mise sur le marché et le suivi des
effets sur la santé
après leur mise sur le marché des
produits la loi oblige détenteurs
d'agréments a participé à la réalisation
des objectifs du plan ecophyto renforce
la trace idée traçabilité des produits
phytosanitaires ou encore exige que les
distributeurs délivre un conseil global
spécifique individualisé à tous les
utilisateurs professionnels
finalement notre groupe a interdit
l'usagé substances dangereuses pour la
santé ou l'environnement dans les aires
d'alimentation des captages d'eau
potable des dispositions de protection
également été prises à proximité
d'établissements recevant des publics
sensibles hôpitaux maisons de santé
en conclusion et vous l'aurez compris le
groupe socialiste ne soutiendra pas dans
sa grande majorité cette proposition de
résolution
si nous partageons totalement dans le
fond son ambition
nous restons cependant très réservé sur
sa forme comme je vienne de l'évoquer
des avancées significatives ont déjà été
obtenus et joël labbé qui a participé
activement aux travaux sur la loi
devenir agricole peut le confirmer
or et certains pourraient le regretter
nous voulons bâtir celle sur des
questions sur ces questions la
réglementation européenne ne nous le
permet pas nous devons au contraire
privilégier le dialogue et la pédagogie
c'est ce que fait le gouvernement
français est particulièrement stéphane
le foll notre mise sur l'agriculture en
demandant notamment
actuellement la réévaluation des
substances actives de la famille des
néonicotinoïdes c'est en ce sens que la
prend la france a pris totalement par
aux négociations européennes sur le
sujet et c'est en ce sens que nous
souhaitons que l'action de la france se
poursuivre
c'est pourquoi dans un souci de clarté
et de lisibilité
le groupe socialiste du sénat déposera
prochainement une proposition de
résolution pour expliquer davantage son
positionnement et je voudrais à la fin
de mon propos cité victor hugo victor
hugo à propos du manteau de napoléon iii
qui était parsemé d'abeilles disait
abeilles piquées les piquer le tout en
même temps
merci mon cher collègue la parole et en
chef daniel le premier pour le groupe
ump
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
madame la présidente monsieur ministre
chers collègues je vais dire d'entrée
notre collègue joël labbé que son texte
sa proposition ne le dérange pas pour ma
part notre part je ne voudrais pas
accusé je voudrais tout simplement
qu'ensemble on réfléchisse aux vraies
questions
les vraies questions c'est que la
culture française est confrontée depuis
longtemps à des enjeux qui ne cessent de
complexifier son activité fournir une
agriculture production agricole de
qualité répondent aux attentes des
consommateurs et du marché limiter les
impacts sur l'environnement
l'agriculture française ne cesse de
s'adapter pour répondre aux enjeux
écologiques
elle ne peut assumer seule le poids deux
mesures qui au demeurant relève parfois
de l'expérimentation
en effet cette proposition de résolution
sans relever d'une utilisation excessive
du principe de précaution
cette proposition de résolution n'est
fondée sur aucune nouvelle étude
scientifique pouvant remettre en cause
cette technique de protection à travers
les insecticides des semences apporté au
moment de ces cultures
quels avantages présente ces molécules
pour l'environnement un utilisateur des
seuls produits utilisés autorisé
aujourd'hui en compte cultures issues du
de ces familles de molécules sont
essentiellement utilisés dans les
productions l'adie de betteraves de
céréales de protéagineux de maïs
d'études chicorée et bien sûr c'est
molécules qui ont l'avantagé d'apporter
une réponse non pas curatives et
préventives
j'y reviendrai soit une solution en
termes d'impact environnemental bien
meilleure aujourd'hui en termes d'impact
c'est 30 % des surfaces de céréales
d'hiver c'est 15 % des surfaces de colza
qui sont protégés aujourd'hui sur notre
territoire
l'intérêt technique
là encore quand on voit les évolutions
avant on traitait systématiquement
l'ensemble des surfaces
un hectare dix mille mètres carrés
aujourd'hui entre est 50 mètres carrés
pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui on enrobe
uniquement la graine on est passé d'une
seconde un dosage de plus de 600 grammes
à l'hectare à 60 g donc ces nouvelles
techniques qui ont permis effectivement
de faire ces progrès considérables
d'améliorer effectivement l'impact
environnemental tout en apportant la
garantie alimentaire la deuxième partie
de mon propos c'est aujourd'hui cette
proposition n'est pas fondée parce qu'on
n'a pas de travaux scientifiques qui
nous apporte effectivement d une thèse
qui nous permette de décider tels que
vous proposez dans votre projet de
résolution aujourd'hui nous avons besoin
effectivement d'aller plus loin dans la
connaissance et surtout nous avons une
nécessité une nécessité absolue de ne
pas placer la culture française
européenne mais surtout françaises dans
des situations de distorsions à savoir
de vivre avec des interdits chez nous et
d'avoir ensuite des produits qui sont
importés qui ne subissent pas les mêmes
règles du jeu c'est la même chose
d'ailleurs sur le débat de gm on n'a pas
le droit je te le dire mais quand on
voit aujourd'hui l'impact que cela peut
avoir sur la performance de notre
agriculture
c'est absolument considérable d'autre
part aujourd'hui la commission
européenne a pris des décisions
ces décisions c'est une suspension
provisoire pour seulement trois
molécules et 7 ce projet de réseau de
résolution va vraiment l'encontre de ces
décisions européennes qui ont été prises
au niveau de l'autorité européenne de
sécurité des aliments
d'autre part cette proposition se fonde
sur un certain nombre d'erreurs
d'erreurs manifestes pour justifier
cette demande d'interdiction
on propose et vous dites
tout simplement que le parlement
néerlandais a décidé de l'interdire
il ya non le nez et gouvernement
néerlandais ne l'a pas interdit
puisqu'il l'a rejetée car effectivement
comme on est en train d'en débattre à
cet instant il l'a rejetée parce qu'il y
avait aucun élément scientifique nouveau
qui permettait de le décider
ce que je voudrais aussi évoqué c'est
des rapports les rapports que nous qui
sont publiés que ce soit par l' agence
française de sécurité sanitaire des
aliments afssa qui a fait un certain
nombre de de travaux qui permettent
aujourd'hui d'avoir une meilleure
connaissance de la mortalité des
abeilles sur ce qui a été évoqué tout à
l'heure par ma collègue sur projet
européen co financé par l'union
européenne sur la surveillance
épidémiologique de la mortalité des
colonies d'abeilles domestiques et là
encore tous ses travaux aujourd'hui
démontre que la mortalité des abeilles
et est essentiellement due à d'autres
facteurs que celui que vous évoquez
d'autre part les constats que nous avons
aujourd'hui à travers une association
l'étude colosse qui est provient de
d'une association à but non lucratif de
recherche sur les abeilles composé de
plus de 360 scientifiques professionnels
à travers 60 pays du monde démontre
effectivement que le taux de mortalité
qui était avant à 37% des colonies est
passé à 9 % l'an passé et qu'aujourd'hui
c'est le varrault qui est l'élément le
plus destructeur qui aujourd'hui affecte
nos colonies d'abeilles d'ailleurs
l'avis de l'agencé nationale de sécurité
sanitaire de l'alimentation va dans le
même sens l'impact économique l'impact
économique est énorme pour notre
industrie agricole puisque l'impact
c'est 4 5 milliards d'euros de pertes au
niveau de l'économie européenne ces
cinquante mille emplois c'est 20 % de la
récolte si on prend l'exemple du pommier
en moi c'est 260 millions d'euros en
moins soit activités de l'arboriculture
je voudrais dire tout simplement en
concluant mon propos
effectivement la bei est un élément
essentiel de la vie et qu'il vaut mieux
aujourd'hui prendre un certain nombre de
décisions de certitudes et les actions
que nous conduisons en france / eco
phyto en font partie et monsieur le
ministre sur les décisions en matière
des grands d'agroécologie là encore on
pourrait aller bien plus loin
le paysan des vosges qui vous parle
c'est qu'aujourd'hui en 2015
nous avons bien moins de terres
labourées killy en 1998 on a 60 % de
moins de terres labourées qui a un
siècle
et effectivement ce que je veux dire par
là la rotation est un élément essentiel
pour la sécurité sanitaire et améliorer
la diminution des insecticides d'air je
termine dernier élément le plan
protéines permettra aussi de faire et je
voulais dire tout simplement en
concluant pour toutes ces raisons je
m'oppose à cette résolution et j'en
appelle au principe de précaution
appliqué à survie de notre agriculture
je ne suis pas favorable au moratoire
mais favorables à un travail approfondi
de recherche sur l'impact des nokia
nicotine aux ide sur l'environnement au
sens large
nous nous sommes unis d' agence de
recherche servons nous en les chiffres
sur la base desquelles nous mais nous
pourrons alors inventé l'écriture de
monde à travers une démarche responsable
envers notre agriculture et notre
écosystème notre groupe votera
majoritairement contre cette proposition
de résolution
merci merci mon cher collègue
la parole est maintenant à monsieur
stéphane le foll
mais oui monsieur le ministre c'est à
vous ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt et
porte parole du gouvernement
d'où son prix
mesdames madame la présidente des dames
messieurs on est donc le réunis cet
après midi pour discuter d'un sujet ça a
été rappelé qu' au fond fait consensus
dans le sens où chacun a bien conscience
du risque qui existe de l'utilisation
d'un dans un certain nombre de molécules
de pesticides qui ont des conséquences
négatives que ça soit sur un certain
nombre de pollinisateurs voir sur les
perturbateurs endocriniens
ça a été évoqué sur la santé humaine à
partir de là le débat y porte après le
discours de joël labbé enflammé qui a
marqué sa sensibilité très forte ce
sujet et qui en a tiré une conclusion au
travers de cette ppl c'était
l'interdiction des néonicotinoïdes en
tout cas invité le gouvernement a invité
le gouvernement à agir au niveau
européen pour l'interdiction le débat
donc porte sur ce sujet chacun ayant et
ça a été rappelé par savary des
arguments scientifiques qui peuvent
aller dans un sens ou dans l'autre
moi je fais rappeler ce qu'est la
position du gouvernement est pourquoi
justement je ne souhaite pas qu'on
adopte cette ppl non pas que j'ai pas
conscience des risques que j'ai pas
conscience non plus de la nécessité
d'agir mais que pour agir efficacement
parce que vous faut c'est ça qu'il faut
avoir en tête
il faut de la méthode et il faut un
ordre dans les choses à chaque fois en
particulier au niveau européen
lorsqu'on s'engage dans un débat
européen il faut qu'au bout du compte on
est pour atteindre la cible la majorité
qui va avec
si je prends la question des
pollinisateurs et en particulier des
abeilles qui fait et qui a fait l'objet
d'ailleurs de beaucoup d'interventions
c'est vrai que la france a vu mortalité
des abeilles s'accroître fortement et la
production de miel baissé elles aussi
fortement le premier constat que le
ministre de l'agriculture a fait ses
clients des sceaux ce multi
factorielle de cette mortalité dans
lesquels il y a les pesticides
j'en étais tellement convaincu que
lorsque je suis arrivé comme isagri
culture j'ai interdit ce qu'on appelait
le cruiser osr qui est une molécule qui
avait tocsin à néonicotinoïdes un
enrobage pour le colza qui de manière
très claire
après un rapport de l'ansès avait comme
conséquence de perturber les capacités
des abeilles à pouvoir rentrer ruche et
donc été un facteur de leur mortalité
interdiction mais comme je connais le
débat à l'échelle de notre pays sur vous
interdisez en france et puis après à
l'échelle européenne des hôtes peuvent
utiliser des produits que nous on n'a
pas le droit d'utiliser on a engagé une
démarche européenne sur la base
d'ailleurs là aussi des recherches qui
avaient été menées au niveau de l'ansej
et donc à l'échelle européenne
au niveau de l'efsa qui ont fait que on
a sur trois molécules sur les
néonicotinoïdes pris des décisions
fortes
au regard des risques pour les
pollinisateurs et qui ont conduit à
réduire l'utilisation de ces
néonicotinoïdes à l'échelle europe
européenne pour toutes les cultures
attractif pour les abeilles
aujourd'hui elles ne peuvent plus ces
substances être utilisé en période de
floraison pour les cultures restantes et
pour les céréales à paille les semis ne
peuvent se faire qu'à la période de
forte ne peut pas se faire la période de
forte activité des abeilles et donc
elles peuvent être utilisées ces
molécules que dans des périodes précises
et l'interdiction de semer des semences
enrobées se fait entre janvier et juin
donc des décisions non seulement aux des
prix en france pour le colza mais ont eu
un prolongement à l'échelle européenne
et nous sommes dans cette situation là
aujourd'hui trois substances lit des
néonicotinoïdes et la pp elle vise à
interdire toutes les substances on nage
a restreint l'usagé des néonicotinoïdes
pour tous
ce qui touche les pollinisateurs c'est
la législation européenne actuelle c'est
pas quelque chose qu'on a à faire c'est
fait c'est fait reste l'ensemble des
néonicotinoïdes ce que vous proposez à
la fois pour des raisons liées aux
pollinisateurs je l' ai dit plus haut si
ça a été évoqué pour ce qu'on appelle
les perturbateurs endocriniens et les
risques pour la santé humaine
pourquoi au fond à partir de ce qui
existe aujourd'hui je suis pas favorable
à ce que le parlement le sénat
ici adopte une position qui vise à agir
pour interdire ce ça consisterait à dire
sur cette question des néonicotinoïdes
et en particulier sur les pollinisateurs
qui a un effet causal direct entre néo
des cottineau ide et mortalité
je les dis dès le début je le sais et
vous le savez on a au contraire une
analyse qui confirme à chaque fois que
j'ai pu discuter avec tous les
spécialistes la multi factorielle it et
des causes de mortalité donc si je
rentre dans l'idée simple qui consiste à
dire si j'interdis n'est notée
néonicotinoïdes je n'ai plus de
mortalité des abeilles
c'est pas un sujet en soi c'est un
problème par rapport aux sujets lui même
et je tiens à être sur le fond de ces
questions il faut qu'on continue à
progresser et pour le faire de manière
régulière
il faut qu'on soit capable d'offrir des
alternatives c'est tout le débat sobios
contrôle et ça manque
c'est pour ça pour la première fois dans
ce plan lle d'ailleurs au débat que nous
avons eu ici sur la loi d'avenir va être
mis en oeuvre ce qu'on a appelé des
certificats d'économies de produits
phytosanitaires expérience qui va être
conduite
je viens vu d'ailleurs qu'ils avaient
des réactions qui était pas du tout
favorable à la mise en oeuvre de ce plan
mais j'irai au bout de ce que nous avons
voté et discuter ensemble ici au sénat
et qui est dans la loi d'avenir et qui
mérite que à partir de là chacun se
responsabilise sur la réduction des
phytosanitaires tous confondus
parce que y va d'une question de modèle
derrière c'est ce que tu évoquais joël
labbé
c'est une pensée globale qu'on doit
avoir c'est une démarche générale
transversale qu'on doit avoir
ça ne se fera pas uniquement en décidant
à un moment donné d' interdire ça se
fait pas ce qu'on est capable à la fois
de savoir là où on veut aller et en même
temps de construire le chemin et la
dynamique qui va nous permettre d'y
arriver
s'ils croient sur ce débat et ça a été
dit d'ailleurs par beaucoup
d'intervenants
il est intéressant et après tout le fait
d'avoir joué alerte et d'avoir invité à
aller le plus loin possible sur
l'interdiction
ça permet de discuter ça permet de
montrer que au sénat on se préoccupe de
ce sujet j'ai bien entendu tous les
sénateurs d'ailleurs personne n'a dit
non non c'est pas un sujet personne n'a
dit oh mais tout ça ça sert à rien
personne n'a dit caricature
donc personne ne doit caricaturer le
débat
ce que je dis est pourquoi le
gouvernement n'est pas favorable à
l'adoption de cette ppl c'est parce que
justement parce qu'on doit pas
caricaturer le débat parce que on veut
réussir l'objectif de réduction des
coûts totalitaire et de l'utilisation et
du recours aux néonicotinoïdes qu'il
faut qu'on soit en capacité
collectivement de mener ces débats à la
fois en assurant les transitions
nécessaires et à l'échelle européenne
en menant les débats de telle manière
qu'on choix dans la capacité d'emmener
avec nous une majorité de pays urbain
parce que c'est pas simplement réussir
en france un projet sur l'agroécologie
même si ça fait partie des objectifs
qu'on s'est fixés et la france va être
leader dans ce domaine
mais c'est aussi faire en sorte que à
l'échelle d'un continent comme ceux de
l'europe on soit capable de faire
évoluer l'agriculture vers une
agriculture durable
c'est comme ça qu'on soit capable aussi
de favoriser la pollinisation et des
pollinisateurs d'utiliser et de produire
du miel
c'est ça les objectifs la france doit
être leader pour qu'elle soit leader il
faut qu'elle soit totalement pleinement
crédible dans ce qu'elle demande dans ce
qu'elle fait à l'échelle européenne
et c'est pourquoi comme ça a été évoquée
par certaines interventions
je ne souhaite pas je ne suis pas
favorable à cette ppl non pas par
l'esprit que la sienne ou sept
cette idée qui consisterait à vouloir
agir pour l'interdiction
mais parce que dans le moment où nous
sommes dans les engagements que nous
avons pris à l'échelle européenne
eh bien il faut le temps nécessaire à
organiser à mettre en oeuvre a assuré la
réussite au bout du compte de ceux
connus souhaitons tous c'est une
agriculture qui soit productive et
compétitive
je crois que personne n'en discute et
tous les débats qu'on a eue sur le web
va venir nous montrer et qu'en même
temps elle soit durable durable dans sa
soutenabilité à long et moyen terme mais
durable parce que aussi l'aviculture est
regardé par tous nos concitoyens
et c'est parce que les agriculteurs sont
des citoyens et qu'ils ont parfaitement
conscience des enjeux
aujourd'hui on doit faire le pari de la
réussite collective merci merci monsieur
le ministre nous allons procéder au vote
sur la proposition de résolution
la conférence des présidents a décidé
que les interventions des orateurs
valait explications de vote
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe écologiste sur
cette proposition de résolution
il va donc être procédé au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 du règlement le scrutin
sera ouvert dans quelques instants
bien mes chers collègues
voici le résultat du scrutin numéro 92
sur la proposition de résolution nombre
de votants 337 nombre de suffrages
exprimés
312 pour l'adoption 64 contre 248
le sénat n'a pas adopté voilà pour cette
proposition de résolution sur
l'interdiction des pesticides contenant
des néonicotinoïdes les néonicotinoïdes
qui seraient accusés et bien intervenir
sur le système nerveux central d abel et
crée une forte mortalité chez les
abeilles
la proposition a été rejetée elle vise
était bien a demandé à la france
d'intervenir auprès de l'europe pour
faire interdire tous les pesticides
contenant cette substance les débats ont
été très houleux
joël labbé sénateur écologiste chef de
file sur ce texte a même retiré sa
cravate en matière de protestation vous
pouvez toujours voir et revoir toutes
les séances sur notre site
publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée à vous sur les
chaînes parlementaires
oh